[Musique]
bonjour pour commencer je citerai
molière qui disait mieux vaut ne rien
savoir que beaucoup savoir à moitié
plein molière scénique l'homme que je
reçois aujourd'hui la particularité de
tout savoir il s'appelle bruno bonjour
brunoh bonjour alors bruno vous êtes
l'homme qui sait tout c'est ça je savais
que vous allez me poser cette question
effectivement je sais tout mais alors
qu'est ce que vous entendez partout à
tous toutes les données les actes et
leurs conséquences j'analyse je calcule
je déduis et surtout gentil c'est peu il
est question que nous sommes en droit de
nous poser c'est quoi la voyez ça vous
saviez pas déjà les cris ekwalla donc ne
dit pas je sais tous ces faux m'a dit oh
bonjour j'atteste que lors de
l'interview autres animateurs criera
koala sans aucune raison apparente juste
pour le tromper amateurs également pour
la diffusion de ce magnéto un pigeon 3
dans la salle je sais tout bravo du coup
mais si il n'y a pas de fenêtre ici
d'accord donc là vous êtes trompés aucun
oiseau n'a pu entrer comme quoi vous
pouvez pas tout savoir moi ce qui
m'intéresse dans votre talent c'est
qu'il n'y a pas qu'un côté ma
connaissance il ya ce côté anticipatoire
médiums voyants attendait mais comment
vous faites pour savoir ce que je vais
pas tu as il était une fois bonjour
madame la baronne
auriez-vous du pape pie populaires ainsi
que l'hymne tartas l'autoroute saignante
merde
bon ok tu sais tout c'est génial est ce
qu'on peut avoir des exemples bah ouais
je peux y alla exactement à l'instant t
combien dauphin dans l'océan indien
vas-y ça dépend où l'écho allegri les
blancs et tous on s'en fout
87 1554 553 un dauphin albinos qui vient
de se faire percuter par un bateau de
marchandises et c'est pas fatiguant
brûlant bien évidemment vous êtes tout
blanc les yeux rouges les gens se
moquent de vous
je parle pas d'être albinos et savez
j'étais en train de vous tester sauf que
c'est moi qui t'ai 6,6 d'accord c'est
moi qui pose les questions
donc on va voir si monsieur je sais tout
s'est vraiment où la capitale de la
nouvelle zélande hington la longueur
dames à 7437 1867 x 345 299 1115 ok si
je vous dis il cortyl à ça c'est
impossible de sisteron d'exception sur
mulhouse stefano dauguet son équipe vous
accueille du mardi au samedi dans un
cadre chaleureux et pittoresque cuisine
méditerranéenne et transalpine
accès handicapés je vous conseille le
suprême de volaille le pigeon françoise
est ce que je peux avoir un verre d'eau
je sais que vous allez soif l'interview
touche à sa fin la semaine prochaine
nous recevrons un invité surprise david
bowie [ __ ] mais qu'est ce que tu
comprends pas dans surprise se
souviendra pas lancé joe allen gastro je
te déteste je sais tu ne sais rien du
tout canoë kayak [ __ ]